الجلوس في المقهى امر طبيعي جدا لكن عندما
تجد نفسك في مقهى او مطعم على شكل زنزانه
او ان يقدم لك الطعام في طبق على شكل
مرحاض فهذا له شعور غريب بالتاكيد تم
افتتاح مطعم المرحاض كراسيه مصممه على شكل
مرحاض وطعام هناك يقدم في اطباق لها شكل
المرحاض ايضا لكن الاكثر غلابه ان لهذا
المطعم زبائنا وعشاقا كثرا اما هذا المقهى
فيسمى مقهى الكوارث في البدايه يقدم لك
فيه الطعام بهدوء تام ثم وفي غفله منك
يتغير الامر يحدث زلزال بقوه سبع فاصله
ثمانيه درجه على مقياس ريختر داخل المطعم
لكنه زلزال مفتعل من اجلك وهنا مقهى الحزن
ومقهى السجن وهذا المقهى بالتحديد يحظى
بشعبيه كبيره في تركيا ففيه يرتدي الزبائن
بدله سجين ويتناولون مشروباتهم داخل
زنزانه شاركونا هل تودون تجربه تلك
المقاهي
[موسيقى]